hi i'm eric singer i'm a dialect coach
have you ever noticed that people tend
to have some really strong feelings
around language use
around the words we use and even the way
we say them today i want to talk about
some of the most common language peeves
where they come from
and maybe even debunk a few of the most
persistent myths
search the internet for language or
grammar pet peeves and you're bound to
find people venting
about other people using expressions
like for all intensive purposes
or a new leash on life these are called
egg corns
no no not acorns egg corns
the original expressions of course are
for all intents
and purposes and a new lease on life but
you can kind of see
where those misheard ones come from they
sort of make sense and they certainly
sound like the originals
i'm going to bring in my colleague
fellow dialect coach eliza simpson to
help me here
hi eliza hi here are some other examples
you may have heard or
maybe you use them yourself it's a doggy
dog world dog
eat dog world you need to nip that in
the butt nip that in the bud
he's a social leopard he's a social
leper curl up in the feeble position
fetal position do you have any favorites
curve your hunger
right that's to curb your hunger cold
slaw otherwise known as coleslaw
card shark which is a card sharp
originally there's a great rick and
morty clip with an egg corn in it let's
have a look
really makes you think huh morty we
should never take things for granted
what i'm just saying life's short we
shouldn't take things for granted
are you saying granite well yeah what i
love about this clip is that i think it
demonstrates the kind of really strong
feelings about language that we're
talking about
it's granted with a d take things for
granted
did you actually think it was jesus
christ rick
even super educated super genius rick oh
you like that huh
i bet that really blows your mind i mean
yeah it's kind of great he's misheard to
take something for granted
as to take it for granted all his life
so
i love egghorns i think they're really
fun and creative they're also an example
of the way that language changes over
time
egghorns are a kind of transitional
stage there are lots of words and
expressions in the language completely
official correct words and expressions
that began as the same kind of creative
mishearings
as these egghorns these are called folk
etymologies
a folk etymology is basically an egghorn
that has crossed over the line from
being
wrong or incorrect or misheard to being
in fact the only
right correct accepted version of a word
or a phrase
a burger actually comes from
hamburg the city of hamburg with the er
at the end meaning
someone who comes from there but it gets
reanalyzed as ham
plus burger so we can take that part out
and go oh it's a burger
shameface was originally shame-fast with
fast meaning to be
frozen or stuck in place so to be stuck
in place by
shame shame fast but that's kind of
archaic and so
shame face seems like it makes more
sense but that's now correct
the word female is not etymologically
related to the word male
at all it comes from old french female
and when it came into english it was
like oh that's like male so
it became female cockroach comes from
spanish cucaracha
and has nothing to do with or roach
both
existing english words at the time that
it was brought into the language and
woodchucks have absolutely nothing to do
with either wood or
chucking it the name comes from an
algonquian language
in narragansett it's okuchwan which
sounded like woodchuck
so by all means enjoy the egghorns that
you find in the wild and maybe don't use
them in formal writing
but let's have a little perspective here
today's creative mishearing
is in fact tomorrow's unquestioned
correct usage
next i want to talk about vocal fry and
up talk
you might associate vocal fry with
speakers like kim kardashian and i
realized it was just the lighting or
lena dunham
my team's just been amazing and i've
gotta give all my love to my team
so what is vocal fry your vocal folds
which are right here
vibrate very very rapidly when you're
producing normal voice what we call
modal voice
uh that's probably about 180 200 times
per second it's so fast you can't even
hear the individual pulses
but if i slow that way way way way down
by using
a little bit less air maybe i'm putting
a little extra tension in here
you can start to hear the individual
pulses of my vocal folds coming together
[Music]
so you can try this at home let's all
start on modal voice going
uh and then lower your pitch down until
your voice starts to creak it may help
if you start to sort of run out of air a
little bit
uh
now i'm almost so what is up talk or
up speak it's going up at the end of a
sentence going up with your pitch using
a rising tone
hi my name is eric linguists call this
high rising terminal terminal at the end
of a sentence
so these two vocal behaviors fry and up
talk come in for a lot of criticism
so what do people complain about well
they complain
that fry and up talk both can make you
sound less intelligent
less sure of yourself less trustworthy
less competent
less educated even less attractive
vocal fry is sometimes claimed to damage
your voice
in fact one thing that's hard not to
notice is that most of the time when
people are complaining about vocal fry
and up talk they're complaining about
women's voices and especially
young women and it's not just women who
do this let's try our own experiment
shall we let's take one sentence the
first sentence from the gettysburg
address
i'm going to do it with some creak in my
voice four score and seven years ago
our fathers brought forth on this
continent a new nation
conceived in liberty and dedicated to
the proposition that all men
are created equal eliza would you do the
same
four score and seven years ago our
fathers brought forth
on this continent a new nation conceived
in liberty
and dedicated to the proposition that
all men
are created equal so what did you think
do you have different associations when
you hear it from
a male voice four score and seven years
ago and then when you hear it from
a female voice four score and seven
years ago
so creaky voice actually has a
linguistic function in some languages
in danish for example the word without
any creak in your voice means she but
the word
means dog so you have to actually put
that creek in and you can change the
meaning of a word
in burmese ka means shake
and ka means attend on you have to add
creaky voice and it means something
totally different otherwise the syllable
is exactly the same
the mexican language khalapa mazatec
actually has a three-way contrast
between
modal voice creaky voice and breathy
voice so we could take the same syllable
which with that tone means tree but if i
do it with breathy voice
yeah it means he carries and if i do it
with creaky voice
yeah it means he wears same syllable
so if creek is a linguistic feature of
some languages you're doing it all day
long
it can't be damaging for your voice i
think we can put that one to bed
next up grammar rules eliza sometimes
people
literally light their hair on fire when
other people mix up
your and your or use apostrophes for
plurals
or those signs in the grocery store that
say 10 items or less
right because we're supposed to use the
word fewer for that right where did that
come from
the idea that we should say 10 items or
fewer instead well let's let's talk
about that
but you know i can't help but notice
that you just ended a sentence with a
preposition
where did that come from yeah you got a
problem with that can we table that for
now did you just use the noun
table as a verb yes i did let's start
there because that's actually something
that really bugs people
the verbing of nouns shakespeare
wrote but now to task the tasker
and in another play dust dialogue with
thy shadow
turning both tasks and dialogue into
verbs
it's been happening for hundreds of
years here are some examples of some
really common verbs that began life as
nouns divorce
model male host diagnose
salt pepper highlight
mastermind it turns out a lot of these
grammar rules
rules that you learned in elementary
school were just made up
in the 17th or 18th century so ending
sentences with prepositions
the first person apparently to have a
problem with this was john dryden
in 1672 who criticized ben johnson a
playwright colleague of shakespeare's
for saying
the preposition in the end of the
sentence a common fault
with him that rule against splitting
infinitives
to boldly go has a really similar
backstory it shows up
really in 1864 in a book a plea for the
queen's english by henry alford
so these prescriptions are both based in
latin grammar in latin
an infinitive is one word you literally
can't split it you can't put something
between it the way you can between
two go to boldly go in english and you
can't put a preposition at the end of
the sentence
in english you can of course latin was
sort of
held up by very educated people in the
17th
and 18th centuries as the perfect
language
grammatically it's really a very very
different language with different bones
different structure different rules so
to say english should be more like latin
is really pretty ridiculous less versus
fewer it was a guy named robert baker in
and he was really just even expressing a
preference for the way he thought they
should be used or the way he liked to
use them but that then got latched onto
and hardened into a prescription and
beaten into us by our third grade
teachers
it's kind of a weird thing it doesn't
change the way most people speak
most of the time so most people don't
walk around saying
from where did you come and with whom
did you go and on what did you step
we just don't do that but nevertheless
we still have this idea that somehow
it's incorrect
it's not okay next up word usage
almost everybody has pet peeves about
words they feel should absolutely
not be used in certain ways literally
anybody literally of course means
exactly precisely
just like that as i said right in a
literal manner
i am literally talking to you right now
i am literally sitting on a chair
it has another meaning and that meaning
is not the opposite
of literally it's not figuratively as
people sometimes say
it's used as an intensifier i'm
literally dying right now
but this is the thing about words they
acquire new meanings
all the time meanings can drift but
meanings can also be added to
it's part of the process of language
change
here are some other examples
disinterested traditionally doesn't mean
uninterested it means dispassionate
uninvested not having a stake in the
outcome
it is often now used as a synonym for
uninterested
actively not interested in something so
it's acquired that meaning as well
ironic this is a big can of worms so
irony is when something happens that is
unexpected that is the opposite of what
you expect an example might be
rain on your wedding day if you got
married in a desert specifically to
avoid having it rain on your wedding day
that would unambiguously be
ironic verbal irony is just when you say
the opposite is the literal opposite of
what you actually
mean now people sometimes use the word
ironic to describe situations that
are maybe just unfortunate uh or
coincidental
a free ride when you've already paid or
even the good advice that you just
didn't take
so i actually sympathize with the desire
to complain about at least some of these
usages
sometimes there's a shade of nuance or
meaning that feels important and useful
and like it's being watered down or like
it's being lost
the thing is this is just something that
happens and
it is also part of the inexorable
process of language change
the word nice it originally meant silly
or foolish
the word silly did almost exactly the
opposite it originally meant something
like
blessed or worthy before it came to mean
what it does today so you just can't
stand against the tide it's going to
change no matter what
here's something that might help though
english is really flexible language is
really flexible
and words can have more than one meaning
we go on like
that just fine we even have a bunch of
words that can mean their own opposite
take a word like sanction sanction can
mean to approve of
or to forbid and condemn consult can
mean to either seek advice or to give
advice
to dust can mean either to sprinkle with
a fine powder or
to remove it from something so i think
we're going to be okay
with literally you can use it to mean
exactly what you want to use it to mean
and be understood and other people can
use it in a very different sense and
also be understood
that can all coexist together
the central fact of language is that it
changes
and is changing all the time some of the
richness of english in particular
comes from some of these borrowings and
mistakes and transformations and
permutations
and you're allowed to have your own
personal opinions and preferences we all
do
but it's important to have a little
humility and some perspective
and to realize that the forms and
meanings of words are ultimately
determined by the speakers of a language
not by any centralized authorities and
that you simply can't
freeze it in place and nor should we
want to
the diversity of expression of forms of
meanings
is one of the richest and most
fascinating things about language
it's something to be celebrated and to
be enjoyed